je viens de trois pages je viens de
trouver un jeu bordel demi on va jouer
au smac mentos sait très bien ce que
c'est que ça encore je voudrais avant
tout c'est nous c'est fini vous allez
devoir
il va partir de bases aux énormités
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
à jour
[Rires]
c'est le boss de bout en bout qui met à
cauterets juste parce l'inquiète pas non
mais moi le pire des cas il a il a comme
moi il a le blues virus
jia mentos à la vente aussi petit bain
alors les séries si vous arrivez à
cheveux je vais mettre un temps d'une
minute trente
si vous avez très bien passé tout le
manteau c'est à dire de haas jusqu'à
vous avez vous gagné chacun a trouvé sa
garde toujours sa et baroque et vos
cadeaux à 2500 soins de bien-être pour
deux personnes privées jacuzzi massages
du corps lâcher prise avec viva louf
[Applaudissements]
je vous rappelle que celui tu ne joue
pas le jeu et contre le public je sais
ça attention ces prochains temps plein
dans la mouche en entier attend oui mais
quand je le met dans ma bouche
will en l'air je le prendrai quelqu'un
avec gilles vincent
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'allais galoche naulleau vous rigolez
mais mettez moi c'est moche alors c'est
pas et que c'est la bouche mais je vois
je la paie est parti le public de crier
avec moi non
[Applaudissements]
attention
c'est parti ouais ouais
où
[Applaudissements]
toujours tomber à l'endroit où les deux
m
ici et donc c'est une non pas de
sensation de ce qu'on fait c'est
faisable mais n'ont pu tous les partis
est temps que vous permet des deux
cadets dans au moins s'il vous plaît las
voilà c'est ce qu'on appelle le triangle
des bermudes dans le milieu du manteau
c'est à dire qu'on a deux personnes
s'ils n'ont pas de dents et une personne
n'a pas d'où ça repart ensuite si ça
repart mais si on passe c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
c'est une
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça s'appelle les cinq mondes tout ça
c'est un truc de ouf
ces raisons il a quand même fait genre
il est dégoûté jeunes et venez faire un
gros plan c'est le manteau ce plus
dégueulasse tout la regarde ce mec c'est
une régie maintenant d'accord le typhus
sur ma ville et ma femme attend même pas